Chicago's mayor and police
superintendent say they're furious that
actor Jesse Smollett is no longer facing
criminal charges prosecutors dropped all
16 felony counts yesterday with little
explanation
Smollett is accused of faking a racist
homophobic beating allegedly because he
was unhappy about his pay on the show
Empire he denies that I've been truthful
and consistent on every single level
since day one I would not be my mother's
son if I was capable of one drop of what
I was accused of our own Adriana Diaz
asked the lead prosecutor why they
dropped the charges believe that he is
innocent I do not believe he's innocent
so you believe he's guilty yes so why
drop the charges our priority is Violent
Crimes and the drivers of violence Jesse
Smollett is neither one of those Chicago
Mayor Rahm Emanuel called the decision a
whitewash of justice CBS News legal
analyst Ricky Clayman is with us Ricky
this is so hard to understand so
prosecutors think that he's guilty
why drop the charges and by the way why
not inform the police superintendent or
the mayor ahead of time well there's a
mouthful in there question number one is
this is totally not typical they have
tried to put it off to the public as
this being the usual course of business
for a nonviolent first-time offender oh
do two days of community service forfeit
your bond $10,000 you're just like
everybody else this is an example of
justice for the rich and powerful versus
justice for the poor I don't see it as
any different from the rich people who
got their kids into college by untoward
means because they had money in power
and what you have here yes they could
have come to an agreement the defense
lawyer and the prosecutor to do
something like what we call continued
without a finding or an adjournment and
contemplation of dismissal these are
legal terms where you get six months to
be able to be on good behavior and you
would pay much more money you would
think that you would have restitution
here you would admit guilt you would do
an apology to the entire
of Chicago none of that happened here
and how does it get worse I'm sorry
Johnny how old would you how does it get
worse
who gets out there first the defendant
and the lawyer get out there first he
gets to proclaim his innocence so we all
think or at least I'd be luring me
things well what was wrong with the case
was there something wrong with the
brothers do they go arrest the brothers
if he is then telling the truth and it's
only hours later that the prosecutor
corrects this and also Ricky prosecutors
and police have to work together on all
kinds of other cases doesn't this create
some bad blood for all those other cases
because of what you just described there
is no doubt about that let's take a look
at what happened yesterday
superintendent Eddie Johnson mayor rahm
emanuel where are they they're at a
police graduation they have new recruits
coming into the department they are then
informed of this decision if you are a
prosecutor dealing with someone who has
crossed the city all of these resources
all of these man-hours and you have
known that this is a crime of lying to
lovelies who are the people you would
notify first before you did such an
amazing act as this one you would notify
the police this this is what you intend
to do you would have the police come to
a press conference with you and in this
case lest we forget the FBI was also
looking at this case I'm sure they
weren't notified either and these were
charges brought on by a grand jury mind
you well how would you feel if you were
a member of that grand jury you heard
all of this evidence you returned an
indictment for 16 counts how did yours
feel in the future about their word
being disregarded this is not the
typical nonviolent first-time offender
this is a person who according to this
prosecutor we just heard him is guilty
was not the victim of a hate crime who
took a look at what happens in the city
of Chicago that is roiled by race and
what he does is he casts himself in the
role of a victim turns the city inside
out and then it turns out that he's
lying he when when mayor Emanuel says
this is a whitewash when Eddie
Johnson and mayor Emanuel come forward
and talk about has he no shame I want to
just add one thing while I'm on this
roll this is a person who started this
if he is guilty and we know that the
prosecutor says he's guilty because he
wanted publicity
what have we wind up with no
transparency no public forum something
that is done quickly and quietly in an
emergency and not have a trial where
they wanted a camera in court to clear
his name and the case is sealed per the
defense's request
so many questions rikiei know we are all
exercised and curious about this play